paying off virtually everything that was
set up in the last 11 years of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe Avengers end
game truly feels like the culmination of
the 21 films that preceded it the film
team achieves this by tying up tiny
stories calling back movies they
released years ago and confirming lots
of fan theories and then Marvel execs
took it one step further by including
basically everyone who's ever starred in
an MCU movie and giving them a role in
endgame case in point that mysterious
kid at the end of the film that everyone
is bending over backwards to remember
warning were now entering spoiler
country after the Avengers faced off
against Thanos and won they assembled
once more for a heartbreaking reason to
attend the funeral of Tony Stark who
sacrificed himself by snatching the
Infinity stones away from the purple
faced despots then snapping his own
fingers in order to blast Thanos and his
alien minions into oblivion the funeral
scene begins with heroes gathered around
Tony's beloved Pepper Potts and watching
a hologram message Tony recorded the day
before the Avengers traveled back in
time to collect the stones
it ends with a solemn sweeping shot of
Tony's closest friends watching his
original arc reactor float across the
lake but a genuine pop-culture mystery
has arisen from all this melancholy
don't move
you got me audience members are having a
hard time remembering the brunette hair
teenage boy standing completely alone at
the funeral who is he and how did he
know Tony we have the answer for you the
character was just a precocious young
boy when he last popped up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe way back in Iron Man
3 he's Harley keener portrayed by actor
ty Simpkins you may also recognize the
actor from his 2015 appearance in
Jurassic world if you can't recall
here's how Harley and Tony first met
searching for food shelter and a place
to recharge his suit
Tony breaks into the garage of Harley's
home in Rose Hill Tennessee the two
characters form an unlikely but
incredibly sweet bond in the film
throughout his friendship with Harley
Tony softens and reveals his fatherly
side aside we also saw when he mentored
Peter Parker and spider-man homecoming
when Iron Man 3 opened in theaters in
2013 Simpkins was just 11 years old
now he's 17 which explains why he's
virtually unrecognizable in Avengers
endgame those who keep a finger on the
pulse of all things Marvel might not
have been entirely shocked to see Harley
Kiner make an appearance in the film
Simpkins casting was confirmed way back
in October of 2017
Simpkins physical appearance came as a
bit of a surprise though since he's now
a teenager and not the tiny lad in Iron
Man 3 but it was never a secret that he
was going to figure into Avengers
endgame somehow when the news of
Simpkins join an Avengers end game went
public
fans wondered if Harley would play a
substantial role in the movie after
spider-man disintegrated an Avengers
infinity war some folks wondered if he
nor would step into his shoes and become
Tony's latest protégé
but others hit the nail on the head and
predicted exactly what ended up
happening Harley was also a victim of
the decimation and his involvement in
endgame consisted solely of a brief
somewhat confusing cameo maybe he had
only a few seconds of screen time and no
lines to deliver but Harley's appearance
at tony's funeral still made quite an
impact the MCU began with Iron Man over
a decade ago in 2008 and with the
characters passing in Avengers endgame
the superhero franchise as we know it
has come to an end it only makes sense
that everyone who admired Tony would
attend his funeral to say goodbye even
the young boy he met all those years ago
as much as Tony tried to resist
friendship and intimacy earlier in his
life he was clearly loved by many check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you